so today we're talking about a little
bit of battlefield xp farming and some
missing features as well as the gta
trilogy getting pulled from pc stores my
name is devonte and you're watching
gamespot news
let's start with battlefield 2042
because it is out now in early access
for a subset of players and now that
it's live we're learning more about its
features and functionality like the game
doesn't have the traditional type of
scoreboard featured in past games dice
never said it would but people are still
sharing their opinions about this on
reddit and social media and asking the
studio to add the scoreboard in an
update there is also no server browser
another staple of the series that allows
players to select maps and modes that
they want to play instead of entering
the matchmaking hopper adding to this
battlefield 2042 has no in-game voice
chat the developer said during a
briefing attended by the washington post
that their analysis found that many
people instead use discord or the system
level chat features on xbox and
playstation that said dice plans to add
voice chat to battlefield 2042 in an
official capacity after launch and
potentially as soon as day 25 which
would be sometime in december
and in other battlefield news players
have found a way to farm xp using the
game's portal mode because of this
updates and hard server resets have
already come to the mode in order to
fight the issue and other quote bad
behaviors a look at the mode server
earlier today showed numerous xp farming
servers with names like one hp bots xp
and fast xp because players can create
custom servers with highly customized
rule sets in portal mode it seems like
one of the first things players thought
of was how to most effectively grind hp
in order to rank up and unlock more
weapons and attachments well according
to the official battlefield direct
communications twitter the effectiveness
of the xp farming servers in the mode
have been reduced although the tweet
does not go into detail about what
exactly was changed the development team
also performed a hard reset on all of
the servers for the mode in order to
free up space
moving on to the gta trilogy definitive
edition because it has been pulled from
the rockstar games launcher which is the
only place to buy the game for pc
adding to this the rockstar launcher has
also gone down spotted by vgc a gta fan
claims to have found the main scm film
within the definitive editions code on
pc which is described as the holy grail
for each title the files are said to
include cut content and messages from
rockstar north developers some believe
this is part of the reason why the games
have been removed from the store so what
do you think of the definitive gta's
because as excited as i was before
i'm i'm mixed now i don't i don't really
know how to feel now that they're out
but alright the playstation 5 was
released on this day one year ago and to
celebrate the anniversary sony has
announced new usage stats and revealed
the most popular ps5 games so far in a
blog post sony's jim ryan confirmed that
more than 360
like you know i know it's placed in like
xbox 360 forget it more than 360 games
have been released on ps5 in the past
year and players have collectively spent
more than 4.6 billion hours playing on
ps5
looking ahead ryan said that there are a
great many additional ps5 games to look
forward to including more than 25 in the
works at sony's own playstation studios
as for the top played ps5 games based on
gameplay hours epic's fortnite leads the
way in second place is call of duty
black ops cold war followed by fifa 21
nba 2k 21 and assassin's creed valhalla
rounding out the top five
so let me know what you're playing this
weekend i got a full play i gotta jump
back into far cry 6 i got to play more
forza i got to finally touch that animal
crossing dlc that i bought and haven't
played yet
the forgotten cities calling my name i
kind of want to play skyrim again
how do we get another day in the weekend
[Music]
[Music]